I think it's terrible you want another
tooth I think it's a disgrace what's
going on in this country I think it's a
disgrace and when you look at that and
you see that and so many other things
what's going on a lot of people should
be ashamed of themselves and much worse
than that as they have cherry-picked
information from the FISA application
they've also cherry-pick information
from mr. McCabe including information he
provided to us about the genesis of the
investigation which did not involve the
dossier the only area that I am familiar
with that we left out would be the the
history of Carter page I explained why
we left this out to the director of the
FBI the director FBI is well aware of my
concerns about mr. page well a lot of
focus on the memo released today
Declassified and the allegations of FISA
abuse top Senate and House Democrats
have issued a letter to the president
saying quote we are alarmed by reports
that you may intend to use this
misleading document as a pretext to fire
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
in an effort to corruptly influence or
impede special counsel Bob Mulder's
investigation we write to inform you
that we would consider such an and
warranted action as an attempt to
obstruct justice in the Russia
investigation
firing rod Rosenstein DOJ leadership
where Bob Muller could result in a
constitutional crisis of the kind not
seen since the Saturday night Massacre
referenced to Watergate there what about
all of this today let's bring in our
panel byron york chief political
correspondent of the Washington Examiner
Susan page Washington bureau chief at
USA Today and Matt's lab contributor
with the hill
Byron well the first thing on the memo
itself there are two really big points
which is at one it said that the memo
was an essential part of this effort to
get a wiretap warrant on Carter page and
two it said that Andrew McCabe the
number two at the FBI said that without
the dossier there wouldn't have been a
warrant now the one clarification it's
it's not a quote in the that part and I
asked Nunez about that he said that
there was a process to put out the
transcript
mccabe and they would have to go through
that to get the transcript put out but
he says it was an integral part and that
the FBI led with the dossier in the FISA
applications and there's also the
possibility that somebody else who was
in a position to know also said there
without the dossier there wouldn't have
been an application so I mean those are
two really really big things and on the
other hand then you look what you've got
now in the dossier and then you look at
what the FBI the Justice Department and
Democrats have been saying in the last
few days that this would be an assault
on the rule of law that it would would
reveal American intelligence sources and
methods and you ask does it really do
that and I think the answer is no I
agree the question about whether they
could not have gotten a FISA warrant
without the dossier I think that's an
important point it's one that's under
dispute between the two parties
it's a knowable fact about whether he
said that or not and so I'm hoping that
we will know what he actually said
before the committee and what the truth
was on that but I actually think the
most important thing about this this
report out today is whether it is in
fact used for additional purposes for
instance the president's tweet this
morning the president's comments that
you just aired indicate that he would
like to fire some people as a result of
this and if he does that that seems to
me it could be extremely consequential
yeah Matt listen the the hyperbole on
both sides has at times gone off the
deep end leading up to this some
congressmen were hyping this up as the
moment of you know the biggest thing
others were two commentators and others
on the Democratic side they were so
concerned about sources and methods and
what this would do to the institution
but where's the ground truth hearing so
what is it Brett is it gonna destroy our
national security if this document is
released and then document is released
and it's called a nothing burger there's
nothing in it it's not very important I
think the Democrats who have been
critical a Devin Nunez need to pick a
lane and I think it's important I think
you're right there has been hyperbole
the one thing I would say Brett is this
is not the breaking this
is not going to break the back of those
folks who used the federal government to
try to go after a political opponent
this is one step we're gonna learn more
and I think it's very important to take
a breath and to take a step back and say
because a lot of conservatives don't
like fights they don't like the
government having this kind of authority
they don't like the government spying on
Americans are we okay with one
administration using these powers to go
after their political opponents I think
that is very scary but there were two a
trump appointed deputy Attorneys General
that continued the fights of
surveillance no that's exactly right
what does that tell you I think it tells
you that they might the current one
might have some job security issues
number one and I'm willing to give him
the benefit of the doubt but if you read
the FISA memo it is alarming that this
was so this was done clearly to
advantage the Democrats and Hillary
Clinton why would they want to continue
it and there's a couple things and even
the Russians said Carter page was an
idiot they didn't want to use them as a
spa couple things to jump out memo
number one graphic September 2016
Christopher Steele admitted to then
associate Deputy Attorney General Bruce
or who his wife worked for fusion GPS
who put this all together his feelings
against then Canada Trump when Steele
said quote he was desperate that Donald
Trump not get elected and was passionate
about him not being President Barron I
think that part his personal animus
toward Trump is less important than the
fact that the the dossier was actually
an oppo research product funded by the
Democrats but I do think maybe the most
one of the most beneficial effects we
are seeing right now is that the release
of this memo has created a lot of
momentum for the release of more stuff
now we what did McCabe tell the
committee we want to see the McCabe
interview what's really in the FISA
application we want to see that too so I
think that's a good thing that we and
what's in the Democrats letter we need
to see more rather less quickly Susan
overlooked I think in that the end of
that
you Nunez said more is coming there will
be other memos this is phase one just
focused on FISA and two there are
rumblings up on Capitol Hill that there
will be an official call for another
special counsel yeah you know the to
Matt's point I think what's interesting
is not the partisan divide on this which
is predictable
it's a divide within the Trump
administration between the FBI and the
Justice Department one side and the
White House on the other side on whether
it was proper through the assist report
and that does not have the partisan
tinge that the divide between Democrats
and Republicans have